I do have a sperm donor but you dill
yeah kolkar - ian is thinking about baby
number two was I just like born to
believe I need to have so many kids I
don't know but hold up her potential
sperm donor is someone we did not see
coming in a new clip from Thursday's
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
Chloe reveals she's been freezing her
eggs I've been doing hormone injections
for about five days and the injection
process has been fired I don't know why
I'm like oh okay it's not that bad
the reality star then tells her sisters
Kourtney and Kendall that a sperm donor
could boost her chances of getting
pregnant again yet dr. Wong was saying
the bonus of doing embryos you get to
see like what are your stronger embryos
which are healthy you get to already
know all that by mixing little sperm see
which I do have a sperm donor but you do
yeah
do you can I see a picture interestin oh
my god yep
Tristan Thompson basketball player
ex-boyfriend baby daddy and now
potential sperm donor
wild it is what it is but we have to
admit Chloe and Tristan do make a really
cute baby what are you wearing my
princess I never thought I would have
only one child but I am so obsessed with
her and I love it so much I definitely
don't think I would feel incomplete if I
didn't have more but another one would
just add more in love to the house Coley
and Tristan haven't been together since
February 2019 when he did kiss me you
know what Danny don't even go there it's
just I think a little too toxic for me
to keep reliving stuff like that
regardless the exes have made amends
since then
good did you make a wish and
co-parenting baby true is the only thing
that matters I'm really proud at the
co-parenting place that we are in and it
seems like the two are on the same page
about this whole sperm donor situation
after my doctor's appointment
I talked to Tristan because if you can
create embryos and do all the DNA
testing I do think that's the smarter
choice but of course khlo does have her
doubts but it's weird because Tristan
and I were not together I don't know
which way to go like he has to sign like
legal paperwork that he would just be my
sperm donor Wow but you never know like
what in three years if I get married to
someone and I'm like you know what I
don't want that so how did we get here
do you want another baby no no no are
your eggs frozen nope yeah momager Kris
Jenner was shook when Chloe revealed
earlier this month that she is one and
done do you need frozen eggs I'm not
worried about it I just find it so
strange that people find it such a
negative when somebody wants to be
single trust me if I wanted to date I
would date eg spoke to Chloe back in
2019 when she revealed she's 100% okay
with being single I've never really put
that much pressure on dating I'm just
you know whoever you are in a room with
that you connect with and there's
chemistry then that's you should date
but I'm just not even in that headspace
but you never know what will happen
[Music]